already we are making it actually i have
to tell you we have uh
already produced more than 20 million
doses
in our warehouses and we continue as we
speak producing more and more
this is why we said that by the end of
the year which is in
how many five weeks we expect to have 50
million doses
that we can distribute to the world and
i think that we will be able to do it
and
eventually we'll be able to do the 1.3
billion
doses that we promise or we expect to
produce next year
how soon will reach the arms of the
people as soon as regulatory authorities
around the world
give us their permission their
authorization
we plan to submit to all regulatory
authorities
very very soon are we talking a couple
of weeks
a couple of days to submit i would say
and once they give us the green light
our goal is to start shipping in a
couple of hours after we receive
the green light but if someone
approves faster than the other i believe
that the ethical thing to do it is to
start sending
the vaccines in the citizens of this
jurisdiction where they have the
authority to authorize it
because every day it means lives
you've talked about doing over a billion
doses in the coming year but ramping up
production for
the world if this is the vaccine
will require many billions how are you
going to get to that point does that
mean working for instance with rival
companies
right now for the world and for all of
us there is only one competitor the
virus
but i would say definitely that the way
that the industry stepped
up to this challenge and collaborated
together
to find to to bring an end to this
pandemic
and the fact that uh eight nine months
after the start of this project we have
uh
readiness to manufacture and get
approved for vaccines of this efficacy
definitely it is
something that will redefine the
industry
and on that question distribution
clearly the pandemic has hit everybody
it's hit rich countries
it's hit poor countries rich countries
can afford to give you more money for
this vaccine
than poorer countries how do you wrestle
with that that quandary i think uh
there is a serious ethical consideration
in the way that we have decided
to to deal with it it is
that we will have a tier pricing
with those countries we said that we
will give it at
a not-for-profit basis in our case
which means the lowest possible
price so that we can make it all
successful to them
just a few others talking of challenges
let me look at my country united kingdom
on january 1st we'll have a whole new
customs arrangement
with your continent europe how does a
company like fisa deal with these big
seismic changes at a time when everybody
can see the common good in moving these
vaccines around and across borders
i i don't think it is a secret that uh
our company together with all
uh the corporate world
was not fascinated with the idea that
the uk will
separate from from europe but you know
we face the reality that this is the
will of the
of the united kingdom's people and we
are working years now
to fight to come to a
to a solution when this transition
happens and and i want to ask you what
is your message there are still skeptics
around the world
most people have celebrated this some
people have said it must have been
rushed through it can't have been tested
properly
that they worry about it how do you
reassure
those people something went very wrong
and that something was
in the u.s and that was the
politicization of this
uh process it became a political
statement if you were not a mosque in
the u.s and it became a political
statement
if the vaccine will come quickly or not
quickly and
that didn't help at all everybody
started
discussing about scientific topics
with political instead of scientific
terms and people got confused
the decision to vaccinate or not will
not affect
only your life which at the end of the
day is your call
unfortunately will affect other people's
lives
because if you don't vaccinate you are
becoming the weak link
that allows this virus to replicate
so i would ask uh
them really to to think it twice and
listen to the experts
i've just got a couple more thoughts one
is that whenever i talk to people about
a vaccine one question always comes up
which is
when can we go to the cinema safely when
can we go to a football match and not
worry when can we get back to normal
life
and when do you think we can i
i believe that uh in the second half
of 21 will be a very different
experience for many of us
because the light is is real
there is light at the end of the tunnel
so
let's be patient and uh
soon this will be over
and for you on a personal level you're a
scientist
you're the boss of an enormous company
and you've had eight grueling months of
research
right now on the back of this success
how do you feel personally when you are
in this situation
you really feel it on your shoulders
um the moment that we were i received
the call
but we have an effective vaccine and
then 10 minutes later
i was informed about the
level of efficacy the 95 96
that i mentioned before it's
the most brilliant day of my life
i couldn't describe with words
the relief and the feeling of purpose
but i felt at that point i knew that
this is a decision that determines the
future of the world
not of uh my company or my family and
i was feeling very
very lucky to be in this position and be
able to do what i did
how did you celebrate
i with relaxation i allowed myself
to to take a few hours without thinking
about
the vaccine and enjoy my family
nothing fancy but that enjoyed my family
involved a lot of wine
well i'm glad because in minds your team
and my celebrated with cup of tea
so i'm hoping someone somewhere cracked
open a bottle of champagne but
let's not forget that i'm greek and we
celebrate differently than you
thank you very much indeed and we wish
you
the very best of luck thank you
we will need it